welcome back now Molly Russell was just
14 years old when she took her in life
after looking at images of self-harm on
social media and this week in response
to pressure from Molly's father in
Instagram announced plans to ban graphic
self-harm images from their platform
however my next guest says that more
needs to be done to protect young people
online we can introduce you now to the
shadow health secretary Jonathan
Ashworth and thank you very much for
being with us you've been investigating
haven't you and a whole host of things
absolutely Matt on social media and the
internet what have you found
book kind of safer so I'm the father of
two girls a seven year old and a five
year old
I love the modern or anything in the
world it makes me feel physically sick
to know that someone's daughter or son
can access material which glorifies were
Munsif Manta sizes self-harm and suicide
and it's still on Instagram by the way
despite what their efforts to take it
out that glorifies and romanticizes
anorexia and other eating disorders but
there's other there's other public
health problems on there as well I mean
I've been doing just a few hours
research this week you know I found anti
vaccination messages being pumped out
directed at parents this is at time
we've got measles outbreaks increasing
and whooping cough outbreaks increasing
and fractionation rates fall and good
it's really easy to get access to
prescription drugs and illegal drugs I
found somebody who's prepared to sell me
son acts on on social media and this is
a time when we fought around something
like 200 deaths from son axe abuse since
2015 or sleeping pills sleeping pills
with commits easily split slimming pills
honestly people's can easily be sold so
how are they able to be appetizer ray
this is happening now on social media
and it's fueling a public health
emergency and what we're saying in the
Labour Party Tom Watson said this
earlier this week is that we now need a
tougher regulatory regime governing
these social media companies we need a
duty of care which is enforced because
these platforms shouldn't be allowing
these sorts of messages to be pumped out
there these images to be pumped out
there to be easily accessible when it's
causing so much harm is there anything
that you know you've been saying that
you've been looking into this yourself
you mention the fact your father it's
something in particular that you looked
at and saw and thought this is why it
needs to change what walks stood out for
me I mean I mean I mean I don't want to
encourage people to go and look at this
stuff but it makes so easy to find
absolutely horrifying images of
self-harm and suicide horrifying images
or horrifying Facebook groups of women
just tend to be young women but not
exclusively young women saying I will
fast for an hour if you give me another
like because a part of a an anorexia
Facebook group or absolutely foul
anti-vaccination messages being pumped
out telling parents not to vaccinate
their children this is a time when
people are dying from measles across
Europe at levels we've not seen for
years because some of these anti
vaccination messages I mean I should
emphasize it's not just about social
media it's also comes a time when mental
health services have been cut back
children a quarter of children are
turned away from cams and a lot of the
public health workforce is being cut
back so we've got to look at the broader
picture about as to why some of these
social media has certainly changed the
climate absolutely social media has
changed the climate and is it's not just
about mental health that gets a lot of
focus in the media at the moment for
quite quite understandable reasons it's
about access to prescription drugs and
illegal drugs
it's about anti vaccination messages and
it's and it's about a kind of lack of
oversight of some of things being sold
on social media which you won't be able
to walk into a chemist and buy it's take
a while what's the solution because
pointing out these horrific things is in
some ways the easy bit so these are the
these are things that shouldn't be
happening but what can you actually do
and what are you suggesting tangibly I
mean you'd saying that social media
company should be publishers they should
be responsible for the content on their
platforms you saying that people
shouldn't be able to be anonymous on the
Internet what is it well social media
companies should be held to account
there should be a clear duty of care
legally enforced upon them what does
that mean well it well it means for
example but if they are allowing these
images and these groups to
to persist on on social media then they
should they will be found in breach of a
duty of care because they still don't
bring their ball Tom Watson has said for
example that if they're not prepared to
deal with these messages which are
called causing harm they should be fined
they should be fined four percent of
their how do you determine whether or
not they are failing the duty of care
well it's quite obvious if they're
causing harm if they're putting if
they're if they're persisting in having
these these these pictures which glorify
romanticize self-harm and suicide that
means that's pretty clear to me that
they're causing harm young people
shouldn't be seeing that I mean we're
having a discussion about this on your
shirt I mean you take it quite rightly
taking editorial decision not to show
some of it on on the screens presumably
so you so so you use your judgment in
deciding what is an appropriate thing to
publish and they do have agency in this
they do curate this because they build
algorithms into their platforms
algorithms which they use for firms who
want to market and advertise on social
media they make money out of this so
they do have responsibility to act and
at the moment they're getting away with
things which you shouldn't be getting
away with what do you do as a parent how
do you control your own children screen
I mean my I mean my kids are not on
social media thankfully so well there's
seven or five but you know that I've
been but my 7ul is already asking about
snapchat I mean I'm on snapchat don't we
not understand how to use it the roadie
asking about it and I mean I can come in
you know I you know I've got my iPad
with me here today but if I if I go home
they'll one of them they'll they fight
to get my iPad so they can watch YouTube
and watch all kinds of absolute rubbish
on YouTube challenge preparedness is a
huge challenge for parents and I'm keen
to ask you about brexit of course
and because Labor's position has changed
this week Jeremy Corbyn setting out his
demands for Theresa May on what he would
see to be an acceptable brexit deal what
I really want is for you to be
absolutely crystal clear if Theresa may
meet the demands that were set out and
Jeremy called was a letter for a
permanent customs union so on does that
mean that labour will back the deal well
then it'll be our deal because we
believe so would you back to do because
it wasn't really clear Matt let's resume
can meet the demands of Jeremy Corbyn
has set out then cereza Mays essential
backing our so will you vote for the
deal if that is what that is what is on
the table then we worked because the
logic of our position okay but we
believe that position will command
support in Parliament we believe it can
bring very divided country together and
we think European Union would be
prepared to renegotiate on that basis
one of the things that was slightly
conspicuously missing from that letter
was any mention of free movement people
so what is Labor's position on that well
we said in the general election our
manifesto of the by leaving the European
Union and free movement and that's still
a position that is a position but we
also recognize that we need to we need
to manage the economy in such a way that
we shouldn't be restricting access to
international labour so in their
National Health Service for example
where we have over a hundred thousand
staff work coming to work here for who
are you nationals and we would need to
continue to recruit from the EU for the
future we're not going to block that
we're not going to end that we've some
coming to work here some in the
parliament are saying that one way of
getting a backbreaker deal through we
could be a kind of Norway plus situation
where you would accept the free movement
of workers and what's Labour's of you on
there I think you see it's very
interesting proposal and that's
something you could stomach well we
could we could we could certainly
explore that but what we want is an
immigration regime which is in the
interests of the economy so we know for
example that public service is not just
in the NHS but social care and other
public services rely on EU workers
coming to work and contribute to this
country there were other areas the
economy which are very reliant on EU
workers as well and of course there are
UK nationals who go and work within the
European Union it's a two-way street
this is so we want a sensible
immigration policy which takes that into
account it seems to me that this is the
week that Jeremy Corbyn picked aside
because he set out in this letter his
view of what he wants to see from a
brexit deal didn't imagine a second
referendum in him do you think a second
referendum is gonna happen personally
and I've said this on on the record I
think he's looking unlikely but our
position as a party still that if
Parliament cannot agree anything and if
it's pretty obvious that a general
election is not going to happen which
that's not necessary at the moment
speculation the newspapers again today
then there could be a general election
but if a general election isn't going to
happen and Parliament is deadlocked then
our position is to leave everything on
the table including campaigning for a
public vote but if you look at jeremy
corbyn's letter our first priorities a
deal the aim was securing a sensible
agreement I mean it doesn't sound like a
man who's campaigning for a second
referendum I thirst not going to happen
my first priority was always been a deal
I mean the general election in 2017 the
manifesto we put forward said we respect
the result of the Praxis referendum I
mean that's always been our position
that's our manifesto position subsequent
to that our confidence is said well if
you cannot get a deal if you cannot get
a general election then you have to look
at campaigning for a public vote now
well I've got you I did want to ask you
about something that Tony Blair said in
my interview earlier on anti-semitism
yeah he said that the leadership hasn't
been robust enough on tackling
anti-semitism is he right I think what
we've seen on understand what is in the
party absolutely breaks my heart I'm
such a big fan of Luciana burger she's
probably Parliament's most persuasive
campaign or our mental health issues for
example I work very closely with her she
stood up against anti-semitism all her
political life
she's got my full support it's clear we
need to go further and faster on dealing
with anti-semitism in the Labor Party
one anti-semite in the Labor Party is
one too many
I mean geometry is so impossible to
eradicate hit them no it's not
impossible to eradicate hit from the
Labour Party and John MacDonald said
that as well so there was no
disagreement between me and Sean only
Corbett on this we all want to get rid
of anti-semitism in the Labor Party and
before there's more stuff in this though
I've had office now they're putting more
resources it the general secretary
journey from is made this her her
priority issue that issue on which
she'll be judged by so we're making
progress but ELISA being robust enough I
think we do need to go faster and
further on this and kick it out I don't
want to be in a party with any
anti-semite okay - well thank you very
much